[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens ces faits graves on
attendra c'est tout ça me plaît pas mais
on peut peut qu'attendre un on n'a pas
l'autre transports à prendre c'est tout
voilà votre challenge quoi votre soeur
elle en pense quoi système j'en ai pas
ça c'est toi
elle fait par exprès c'est vrai mais
massa allait au sein des banques rosport
bonne continuation
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
c'est je trouve qu'ils sont sales et qui
devrait être rénové un peu plus j'ai
appris qu'on changer la couleur des
métros mais un petit peu plus de
nettoyage se ferait pas de mal je pense
et votre frère il en pense quoi
oh [ __ ] c'est cette émission là avec
l'histoire du frère n'ont qu'à des
missions
c'est ça voilà c'est camille castagne
même pas deux mois ont plus quand je
connais d'où on à ken non
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
au club parisien
mais je pense qu'en ce moment c'est un
peu problématique à cause des grèves
mais voilà je n'utilise pas tous les
jours et là on prie j'ai entendu qu'il
ya des grèves là pendant quelques jours
bonjour saint philippe du roule api
voulait aller à pied je ne sais pas là
il faut aller par un opéra par an après
on pleure nouveau imiter mon accent pas
du tout vous avez le bac ça vous venez
de quel pays des portugais
serbie est servi par là où par à l'ess
c'est pas d'la l'eau
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]